[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
over the past week we've heard a lot
about escalation de-escalation and what
is proportionate we've also heard the
word war this is how the US Iran
conflict is described what is not talked
enough about is the necessity of ending
the American military presence in the
Middle East these endless wars must
cease
[Music]
crosstalking the us-iran conflict I'm
joined by my guess Muhammad Miranda and
Quran he's a professor at the University
of Tehran in Washington we have
Christopher Nam he is founder of
American veterans policy Network and an
Iraq war veteran and in Sydney we cross
the ally risk he is a Middle East expert
as well as contributor with al-monitor
all right cross dr. Wilson effect that
means you can jump into any time you
want and I always appreciate Mohammed
let me go to you first here if you were
to believe the media how things are
settling down a little bit after this
tumultuous week involving the United
States and ran and the entire region and
we're going to talk a lot about Iraq
here where do things stand right now
because if we look at it from well
Trump's tweets and whatnot you know Iran
has decided to stand down how do you
feel about that being in Teran go ahead
I think Iran feels that Trump stood down
because when the Iranians launched the
missiles all of them pass through the
air defenses and hit their targets so
they were both accurate and the
Americans were unable to intercept them
so that was a major success and I think
that was a signal to Washington that all
their military bases in the Persian Gulf
region are vulnerable and it also sends
a message to the Saudis their Marathi s
and the Bahraini ruling family that the
Americans cannot defend them against
Iranian missiles and Iran has huge
numbers of missiles and huge numbers of
underground storage centers from - from
where they will fire them in case of war
so Trump who was talking about bombing
cultural sites and 52 target suddenly he
became much more let's say peace-loving
after after the attack so it's the
Iranians feel it's the other way around
but more importantly I think the
Iranians believe that the Americans have
made probably the biggest mistake that
they made among the many mistakes that
they've made
over the past decade and that is that
they've turned the Iraqi people against
the United States they've turned the
Iranian people against the United States
and they've United Iran and Iraq in a
way which we haven't seen before you
know Chris you're an Iraq war veteran I
mean talk about that because that's
essentially what's happened and if you
look at what's coming out of the
Pentagon and other places of power in
Washington DC what where does democracy
actually stand now in Iraq because it
was invaded under the auspices to bring
democracy to Iraq now they have a
parliament in a quorum of the Parliament
it says it's time to go home but
Washington says ah not so fast so what
is the value of the democracy that was
forced upon the Iraqi people in 2003 go
ahead Chris yeah Peter you know if I
could figure all that out I'd be a
genius because it has been unsolvable
since World War one I think this all
goes back to sykes-picot Treaty and
World War one the Middle East has been a
carved up in so many power structures
and it's never fundamentally been able
to come to a resting place where there's
been able to be a harmony throughout
these governments and I would agree with
you that it is just completely difficult
to have this kind of long term
intervention at this point I would I
would certainly agree limiting the u.s.
footprint but the problem is two things
one you know that that resolution is
obviously non-binding it's sort of a
sentiment from the legislature we've
still got reality on the ground of being
able to do things and I think the US
doesn't want to have you know long term
Iranian influence a certain extent won't
have something I would also just but but
isn't that really up to the Iraqi people
I mean why should someone sitting in
Washington DC determine what kind of
friendships a foreign country a
sovereign country like Iraq should have
it seems a very heavy-handed and I don't
see how it adds to American foreign
policy interests go ahead well I think
you're you are right I mean the fact is
I mean they've already had their
opportunity I mean they they wouldn't
even fight for themselves and the with
the Iraqi defense forces we left in
place which is I think the low point of
the war but I would push back a little
bit from my colleague is this idea
of of the you know the this successful
Iranian strike you hit none of us we
just wiped out knocked out one of your
key officers I don't think I don't think
Iran actually really wants to strike
back I think they're worried about the
sanctions I think that this is all
really about the economy and I think
President Trump has learned that's
really where the real war is is being
able to tank their economy and they're
feeling that so I don't think Iran
actually wants to strike back I think
they want to do two things save face and
avoid sanctions okay okay let's go to
you and in Sydney here what has been
accomplished here I mean a professor
Morandi did bring up a good point is
that actually Iran was able to show its
strategic flexibility and strengths
within the region here that is a very
strong message and they launched the
missiles from Iran it wasn't from a
proxy so they were actually sending a
very clear signal and it is the signal
is it's time for foreign military to
leave the Middle East
go ahead a lien in Sydney yeah before I
answer that question just allow me to
respond to what your previous guest said
that Iran wants to avoid sanctions if
that was the priority for Iran I think
that would have went ahead and made a
deal with the Trump administration Trump
wanted to meet with President rouhani
and General Assembly and president
rouhani was the one who rejected so I
think that notion that Iran just wants
to relieve itself the sanctions as a bit
far-fetched now regarding your question
Iran yes this is the first time we see
Iran actually responding to American
bases and announcing it we saw the
Revolutionary Guard actually announcing
that they were the ones who launched
this attack so it appears that we have
indeed
entered a new phase in the American
Iranian confrontation I also have two
heard that isn't just about Iran versus
the u.s. you have many non-state actors
which are allied with Iran that also
could respond and retaliate acceleration
groups like Hezbollah in Lebanon like
the Houthi movement indeed like the
popular mobilization forces in Iraq
these players for them general Soleimani
was indeed an icon and striking ceremony
really was something which which had a
very big effect on them and so in
addition to Iranian retaliation it's
very possible that Iran's allies by to
respond and all of it runs non-state to
actor one of the Iranian Ally so
non-state actors which I mentioned has a
lot of cetera
they've all proven themselves to be a
force to be reckoned with
on the military scale okay let's go back
to trend professor Miranda Soleimani I
mean he was he was murdered and he's
been mourned but his deputy stepped in
immediately so what has really happened
how is the needle been moved by taking
out quote-unquote this murderous monster
whatever you want to say and CNN and all
of that because the policy doesn't
change I mean the rhetoric you know and
the bluster that you that last for what
a few new cycles but we're still back
where we were okay I mean that's why I
think the assassination was senseless
okay because it doesn't affect policy go
ahead Mohammed well a couple of myths
have been destroyed the unpopularity of
the Islamic Republic of Iran at home
through the enormous funeral between
five to seven million people
participated in Tehran alone even the
Western media admitted that it was
extraordinary so it shows the strength
the legitimacy and and the capability
and the anger of the the people of Iran
and the Islamic Republic of Iran the
myth of Iraqis hating Iran and hating
the popular mobilization force because
the funerals that were held in Iraq were
also extraordinary the size the
magnitude in the different cities it
showed that the Iraqis and the Iranians
were actually both very respectful for
one another the the funerals in Iraq
were for the Iranians and the funerals
in Iran will for the Iraqis
as well and then contrary to what your
guests in the United States says
Americans didn't achieve anything they
murdered two war heroes at the Iraqi at
the Baghdad International Airport and
the Iranian commander the Iraq the Iraqi
Prime Minister said he was going to meet
me at 8:00 a.m. he was scheduled to meet
him to discuss a letter that the Saudis
had given because the Iraqi Prime
Minister wanted to mediate and he was
going to give the Iranian response and
the Iraqi Prime Minister said that Trump
knew about it and he welcomed it so this
shows the degree of deception that comes
out of Washington
so murdering war heroes in another
country against the will of that country
in complete disregard of the government
the Prime Minister and international law
and sovereignty is not anything to be
proud about or to gloat about or to to
say you know to even discuss in public
it's something to be ashamed of okay
let's go to Christmas let's go to Chris
were in Washington hey just one tenth it
okay go ahead there's one sentence okay
go ahead go ahead I just wanted to say
on the other hand the Iranian missiles
all were hit their targets and they
destroyed buildings look at the
satellite pictures they destroyed
hangars everything inside them but they
specifically targeted the hangars and
buildings that were full of drones and
helicopters and equipment and they
didn't target the barracks where the
American soldiers were sleeping in so
the Americans tried to murder Iran Ian's
at the international airport but the
Iranians tried to destroy American
equipment inside US base okay let's go
to which side is he may let's go to
krytus let me go to Chris Chris go ahead
before we go to the break here respond
go ahead Chris I mean I've had my fair
share of America bashing for the day
Peter I mean look here's the deal
he was a combat casualty he wasn't
murdered and see I've had some
experience at
where Iran has been funding and pushing
out these proxies to blow a soldier's
eyes out and legs off so do I feel bad
that he died absolutely not I might even
have a beer later and cheers to it and
the fact the matter is this Iran is that
more people died at that funeral I mean
we could talk all day about the barbera
barbarism in Iran I don't think we'd
have enough time so I'm just gonna have
to push back on this America bashing
where I'm with you Peter
I would love to get out of there okay
we're gonna we're gonna talk about that
and this we're gonna talk about that in
the second half of the program here
gentlemen we're gonna go to what should
be murdered we're going to a short break
gentlemen and after that break we'll
continue our discussion on the u.s. Iran
conflict stay with our team
[Music]
welcome back across where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle to remind
you we're discussing the u.s. Iran
conflict
[Music]
okay let's go to alia in Sydney we have
a Gordian knot in front of us and we
have to cut it somehow and the the
Gordian knot is the following Donald
Trump ran as as a candidate in 2016 to
end these endless wars okay bring the
troops home now we have a situation we
got in a very bizarre way in tragic way
but we've gotten to a situation where he
can have his cake and eat it too the
troops can come home they're not wanted
in Iraq any longer and why doesn't he
embrace it it's his campaign promise for
goodness sake and we know the majority
of veterans that fought in those wars in
that part of the world thought the wars
were useless fruitless and in a waste of
time and and you and there's also
anti-war sentiment across the political
spectrum this is an opportunity why
doesn't he grasp it go ahead ally again
I would have to comment on what Chris
said regarding the ceremony and the fact
that ceremony was a casualty of war this
was an operation carried out in warfare
this was a diplomatically sassanids
Soleimani is the member of be or was a
member of these state apparatus of the
military this is like cutting the joint
chief of staff of a country so that's
nothing to do with the casualty of war
and it's unfortunately your guests is
that you know he would celebrate though
as he wouldn't have a beer after the
killing of sulemani when stood a man he
played a pivotal role in defeating Isis
whether it be in Iraq or in Syria Isis
which is the most notorious terrorist
group in the world now in answering your
question I think that Donald Trump has
given a lot of ground if you would like
to the neocon so didn't before there was
you know it was trying to confront the
neocons trying to confront the war group
in Washington but he appears to have
succumbed to certain pressures and
regarding this assassination attempt in
particular I think that in this
particular issue Trump responded to the
wishes or listened to Pompeii or Mike
Pompeo specifically right
the assassination the real mind behind
the other brains behind this operation
was Mike Pompeo Mike Pompeo is an
evangelical he ideologically hates Iran
is supported within Israel at the same
time Trump also has many communities
ready allies we have certain figures who
would support him in his campaign donors
like Sheldon Adelson I think that's the
angle from which we could look at it but
I have to also emphasize that I don't
think that the assassination of so many
is linked to any broader strategy I
think that it just stems from pure
hatred from certain American figures
towards Iran at the same time the it
stems from the ongoing American
evangelical support Israel well let me
go back to Chris cuz I cut him off
because we had to go to a hard break
here Chris you know why doesn't Trump
embrace this this possibility of
bringing the troop home troops home
because he campaigned on that and a lot
of people are backing that I mean you
have even in the other party Tulsi
Gabbard talking about that is that
doesn't he risk losing part of his base
because that's what a lot of people we
don't know the certain percentage but
voted exactly for that why doesn't he
embrace it go ahead Chris well I think
that that option is still available
Peter I mean again though like all
legislators in the world that they do a
lot of talking and a lot of babbling but
the executives still have to deal with
the actual reality on the ground so I
think if that's decisions going to be
made they're gonna have to be prepared
for all of the different logistical
realities that will happen if that fully
comes to fruition but another thing
Peter why are we talking about the
deaths at the funeral from the crowds
and the absolute lunacy over there I
mean why do we never actually fully
cover what's actually going on in Iran
again a government where the clergy runs
everything the every branch of
government is stacked with clergy that
runs the entire government this idea of
the Iranian people are fully United
there's many uranium people that want
nothing to do with the government but
they're afraid so I don't think we're
really getting a full favorite picture
Chris okay I'll give you this even let's
say everything you said it's true what
business
visit of the United States what kind how
the government is run in Iran what is
what what is the problem it's their
country
I would agree I agree with you about
limiting our footprint but I'm saying
while we're still there having to manage
situations there are certain decisions
that have to be made and I just have to
push back on this complete celebration
for military officers that have long
been involved I Roxy ha transmen verse I
am I am seek their hands I want a plan
stay off of it I want to possibly
celebrate the end of these endless wars
that's most important to me okay let me
go to Mohammed in Tehran I mean we just
had a description from Chris here I mean
what how does Iran look at how the the
region is evolving because we and I
think it's only a matter of time before
American troops leave Iraq that means
also Syria how does that change the
geopolitical reality oh I'd like to say
American troops are in Syria illegally
under international law they were not
invited there by the government in
Damascus so they should even go even
faster so how does the political terrain
change go ahead and into them well right
well obviously your guests in the United
States knows nothing about Iran and to
call all those millions of people who
went to the funeral lunatics is an
insult to a nation what I do think is
important is that Trump himself admitted
this is one of the ironies of this whole
episode Trump himself admitted once upon
a time that it was Iran in Russia that
were fighting Isis and Trump also
admitted once upon a time that it was
Obama who created Isis so the the Trump
regime has admitted that Soleimani
because he was the key person who fought
Isis from the very beginning when Isis
was closing in on Damascus he went there
you know we don't have a reason we're
here is we have divided these Chris
Chris Chris Chris Mohammed did Nina
right to you you have a refugee regime
you have a very ugly regime you have a
very ugly regime it is gone this way too
many Iraq 2 million here
keys it has helped and you're intolerant
of opposing views because you keep
interrupting me you have destroyed Libya
you've helped the Saudis Massacre the
people of Yemen and impose a starvation
siege your government has helped create
Isis according to your own president
they have helps the Saudis and others
create extremist groups that have
devastated Syria they have destroyed
Afghanistan the United States helped
create al Qaeda I mean the list
I mean I'm not I'm only talking about
this region I'm not talking about
Bolivia or Venezuela or Africa or us
support for apartheid in Palestine or
South Africa but getting back to the
point they met one of the problems of
Americans is that they be treat the
people of this region with arrogance
they occupy Iraq illegally then they
ignore the government for example just
recently the Americans a contractor was
killed Americans inform the Iraqi Prime
Minister that they were going to bomb
the popular popular mobilization force
the prime minister told him not to do it
they ignored him the prime minister of
Iraq said give me the intelligence they
ignored it this is not the an ally this
is an occupier and the u.s. embassy
being the size of the Vatican is
symbolic of an occupier and an empire so
they go and kill in when one contractor
is killed they won't give the
intelligence but then they go bomb 30
soldiers on the border on Syria 500
kilometers away on the frontline against
Isis why because they wanted to weaken
the Iraqi government footprint on the
border to strengthen Isis because they
want to keep Syria encircled they don't
want trade to take place between Syria
and Iraq because they want to strangle
the Syrian economy so the United States
ignores the Iraqi sovereignty they
murder people at the airport they lie
about it because they said Solomonic
general Soleimani was coming into the
country to carry out an active attacks
against the United States where in fact
he was going to see the Prime Minister
the Western media will ignore all of
this but at the end of the day when the
Araki resistance the u.s. out okay when
I want to get a blame Iran I want to get
to that point cuz they cannot accept the
fact that people in Iraq hate the United
States occupation let me go to Ally on
this here I mean the the the focus in
the media is the the conflict between
the United States and Iran but really
this story at this point in time is
about the fate of Iraq what is the fate
of Iraq here where do we stand right now
well I would have to agree that the US
has dealt big blue to its influence to
Iraq by this assassination we're talking
about so there are many but by the way
you the assassination of the Iraqi
commander of the popular mobilization
forces behind this he is an extremely
important figure as well and that also
is something which received a very angry
reaction from the Iraqis so this wasn't
just an operation again you have to
recall it's not just the operation
against ceremony it was an operation
which targeted a key Iraqi commander who
played a key role in fighting Isis so I
think the u.s. hasn't done itself any
favors whatsoever it did have some
influence in Iraq yes that's true it
might still have some implement that
influence my belief has greatly
diminished at the same time I think that
Iran's influence has risen and
incidentally I think that the US the
policies it's pursuing in the Middle
East I think that they still more from
you know this world view that there is
good and evil as if the US and Israel
are the good guys and Iran and allies
are the bad guys that's not a productive
way strategically does it make sense and
it's also even an immoral policy but the
US continues with it and I think what
we're seeing is basically not just moral
bankruptcy in u.s. foreign policy but I
think we're seeing strategic bankruptcy
as well okay Chris I'm gonna be the last
minute on the program go ahead Chris I
mean just Iran is just a great place
it's just the most benevolent nation on
earth I mean the bottom line is this I
mean the going back to the iran-iraq war
it's not peaceful over there gentlemen
I'm sorry and you know what I would
agree where I think where we all agree
is
I would like to limit the u.s.
involvement over in the Middle East I
would I would like to go in the
direction that that Peters cited but
there's obviously much more complexities
there and frankly a lot of the
opportunity that's been given with a new
government in Iraq has been missed and
that's that's not the the fault of the
United States but well it means war I
mean they're made crisp I mean there the
United States is not faultless in all of
this wouldn't you agree look I think
foreign weapons they gave to Saddam
Hussein well I mean professor Morandi is
a veteran of that war okay and remembers
it very well
I'm sorry Facebook took your profile
down because you used a picture from
being a veteran I mean I don't know
what's going on in the world here all
right gentlemen we've run out of time
here many thanks to my guests in Tehran
Washington and in Sydney and thanks to
our viewers for watching us here at RT
see you next time and remember Prospect
rules
[Music]